has there been any verbal or telepathic
communication i know that there's a
story about
i think zimbabwe africa with aliens
communicating with some children there's
certainly reports of it doesn't mean
that it's
it's see the problem is subjective we
don't know for sure it's
it's the humans interpretation of what's
going on and and here
is why we have to be so careful as you
know in a scientific experiment and in a
closed system
you know the the the the the
likelihood of human error is increased
significantly
and so uh you know we have to be
cognizant of that
um is there some sort of real
communication as you say telepathic
communication occurring
or is it a similar effect to let's say
taking a hallucinogenic
uh drug and having some sort of
experience right
mental experience i don't know the
answer to that
the answer could be yes or no for none
it could be that they're
there there is it's just our it's uh our
impression of what's going on
uh and it's not real right like the
near-death experience a lot of people
report it being real a lot of people say
no it's just
parts of the mind that are beginning to
shut down and you start you know having
these experiences
i don't think anybody really knows for
sure other than the people who actually
experienced it